[Music]
one of the great things about the horror
genre is that it's done
all around the world in very unique and
entertaining ways so in that spirit
we're bringing you guys the top five
korean horror films today on the ketchup
of course ron tomatoes.com is the place
to go for our full list of the best
korean horror movies according to the
tomato meter and trust me
you will be scared we're looking at the
top five from that list starting with
number five
gong jiam haunted asylum oh hitting a
little too close to home for me this one
follows the crew of a web series that
travels to an abandoned asylum for a
live broadcast turned
nightmare this critical and financial
success became one of the most
watched horror films ever in south korea
and it was actually inspired by a cnn
travel article
naming the abandoned gon jion
psychiatric facility one of the
freakiest places on the planet
and they weren't kidding
welcoming itself into the number four
spot is the host
this film takes place years after
american military personnel
carelessly dump chemicals in seoul's han
river when a monster emerges and begins
attacking people
directed and co-written by parasite's
oscar-winning bong joon-ho
shout out to the bong hive critics say
the host is as populist pleasing as it
is intellectually satisfying combining
scares
laughs and satire into a riveting
monster movie
sounds like classic bomb
and pulling into the number three spot
on our list is 2016 zombie thriller
trained to busan
this film which was a massive worldwide
hit and broke box office records in
south korea follows passengers that are
fighting their way through a countrywide
viral outbreak while trapped on a bullet
train so 2020 on a train
another film set in the same universe
trained to busan presents peninsula
actually came out this year as well but
hasn't been as well received
so i guess the train to be on is the
original which critics call a
thrillingly unique and purely
entertaining take on the zombie genre
making itself heard in the number two
spot on our list
is the whaling this 2016 horror mystery
thriller is about a rule village that
links a series of brutal murders to the
arrival of a mysterious stranger
despite the 2 hour and 36 minute run
time the film is a hit with critics and
fans
one audience review from riff j said
it's very suspenseful and entertaining
the long run time flies by has quite a
few moments of total fear and dread
and the atmosphere is great and sucks
the viewer in
and finally number one on our list of
the top five korean horror films is
2016's
seoul station this animated flick about
people trying to survive a
zombie pandemic in downtown seoul is
from the same director's train to busan
young seong-ho and is considered a
prequel to that film as the events of
seoul station take place one day before
the critic's consensus for soul station
is that it's thrilling and relentless
from start to finish and is a layered
and vicious entry into the zombie genre
who knew animated zombies could be so
scary
all right friends it's time for us to
kick it over to you now what are your
favorite korean horror films please let
us know in the comment section so we can
get that conversation going and of
course if you want to check out our full
list
please do head on over to
rottentomatoes.com also don't forget to
check out our brand new podcast rotten
tomatoes
is wrong because fresher rotten is just
the beginning of our convos and new
episodes drop every thursday
and if you don't want to miss out on any
future episodes of this show be sure to
hit the subscribe button and
notification bell and as always we can't
thank you enough for watching the
ketchup my name's as perez
and i'll see you guys next time bye
you